hello uh my name is
josh smith and you are here to
learn all about the fun and interesting
world of
quality control and hopefully managing
some fungal and bacterial risks
so as i said my name is josh smith
i'm the ceo and chief scientist at
premium cbd labs
we're currently located in madison
wisconsin
very very sunny weather here in
late march we had our snowstorm
yesterday so
it's all good i finished my graduate
degree in clinical microbiology
at university wisconsin lacrosse i spent
a little over a decade in pharmaceutical
research
new drug development and you know
i may not be from canada but i prefer
ice hockey and
beer that i can chew so
enough about me unless anybody else
wants to talk about
long walks on the beach
as we all know cannabis is a major
growing industry whether you want to
talk about
medical recreational or hemp it
is going rapidly wildly
every day cbd is in the news everywhere
and even now we have people especially
with this
recent coronavirus outbreak trying to
jump in and jump on the bandwagon with
cd cbd
so it's not just in the united states
but all over the world
the cannabis market is increasing
rapidly
uh and as you can see these numbers here
are from
uh mj biz which is a very nice
publication but for 2020 we're expected
to have between 55 and 66
billion dollars uh for total economic
impact to the united states
[Music]
and it's not going anywhere it's only
going higher um
and as we look in the next couple of
years that
number is just going to be astounding
but since ever all of us are pretty much
in the cannabis space
we all know that and
one of the biggest things about the
cannabis industry and really any growing
industry is
with growth comes growing pains you've
been having
you know you get new government
regulations you get a black market
as uh california can attest to problems
with the black market really hinder your
legal market you get snake oil salesmen
shady businessmen that are trying to
either scam people
and sell them something that's just
vegetable oil
or you're trying to sell them on a
product that you claim can do things
that it can't
i believe the fda even recently
sent out some nasty letters and
smackdowns to
a few companies over claims that cbd can
do
certain things and then
the more a little more of a focus for
this talk
is you know businesses that are
unprepared
for growth or what's coming
mostly regulation and uh
getting their processes up to speed
so as i said what does that mean for us
we get to quality control now what does
quality control actually mean
uh depending on your area of expertise
that can mean a lot of different things
but for us really
the one thing that kind of solidifies
and brings everything together
is you know you're consistent
so your product your process it's going
to be the same
across the board you're clean
your facilities your products you're not
introducing anything you're not causing
contamination
uh and you know safety for yourself
your employees and for the general
public
to help with your consistency and this
is where we start talking about standard
operating procedures
everything also you get into what
companies are you ordering from
are they registered are they reputable
are they
doing proper qa qc on themselves are
they iso accredited
i mean are you batch number and lot
number recording
for your own chemicals and processes
and you know how are you tracking when
you do order
chemicals when you do order uh supplies
how are you testing to make sure that
there wasn't a bad batch from the
supplier
uh cleanliness you know are you doing
cleaning
sometimes it's just as simple as are you
cleaning your stuff are you cleaning
your equipment are you cleaning your
facility
how are you doing that i mean is it
appropriate
for example uh in the lab
you know your bench tops what are they
made out of
some of those materials are very porous
and you can have bacterial and fungal
ores you know bacterial contamination
that they can live in those
pores and no matter what kind of
cleaning you do it's not going to
really do much or if you say you have
a certain benchtop and then you use a
different cleaning product than you
normally would
and it eats microscopic holes into that
benchtop
so really making sure you're using the
right products
and then also how often i mean if you're
doing something once a month
is that going to do much not really
and then are you recording that
because just like uh in the ahr world
if it's not written down it does not
exist so
really make sure you're logging all of
your processes
and your cleaning and all of that
training etc
then we get safety so this is for
yourself
your employees mostly but you know it
also comes down to
what you're putting out and your
customers
but are your employees wearing the
proper personal protective equipment
ppe uh do they understand
the risks this is where are you giving
them the proper training to do certain
things
and you know are they correctly
following those protocols and logging
them
that's the big one you know not somewhat
you get the person who's been doing
something for 20 years a certain way
and it's wrong now you have trained them
and said they're doing it things a
certain way but are they
you know like old manufacturing machine
shops that i grew up working in
how many of those people actually wear
their safety glasses when they should or
where they're ear plugs when they should
in the lab you've got the organic
solvent waste
particularly in your uh to extract your
cannabinoids
are people wearing their gloves how
they're wearing their eyeglasses
are they doing things in a hood are they
doing things in a bio safety cabinet
all of that comes in the playlist
but the nice part about all this is
that we don't need to reinvent the wheel
a lot of people seem to feel or seem to
think that cannabis
in the cannabis industry is something
brand new
while the product is new really
the overall processes are not so there's
a lot of resources out there that we can
get to that we can find that
or this has already been done and
available you know
for example iso accreditation for
whether it's 9001 whether it's 17025 if
your lab
i mean all of those things are there
already you know
that'll that's your sops your quality
control manuals
you know you have auditors and
contractors
and excuse me
people that can help you with that
if you're in a extraction facility
manufacturer
gmp if you're a lab glp
that's good manufacturing practices and
good laboratory practices
i know good man gmp facilities
are expensive to create they take a long
time
hit the audits get the paperwork get the
hr i mean
but there's not going to be less federal
regulation
in this industry it's not going away
the more it gets standardized the more
things go
the more regulations we're going to have
and to be honest
just like in every other industry
especially in
say the food industry as i have in point
three here
the fda already has food grade lab
certifications food grade kitchen
certifications
that's what you need to be going for
it's only going to be a matter of time
before
you're forced to so now is the time to
get ahead of the curve
and get working towards that because
eventually you'll have to and you'll
already have the
auditors in place or you have the
process kind of taken care of
it'll be cheaper and faster for you to
get your
products while everyone else is waiting
probably you know one to two years
minimum and then also
you know for growers there's already
usda programs out there for
various uh certifications
that these are all great resources
especially
the fda has a great small business
resources
while they can sometimes be a pain to
work with
as most government agencies can be they
their online portal is actually very
good at getting through
and giving you the information you need
and showing you the exceptions that you
can apply for
[Music]
now this to break this down a little
more
you know again quality control means
different things for different
industries
if you've got a grower or farmer
both indoor and outdoor you've got
different things to think about
as pertains to you know your funnel and
bacterial risks and your quality control
in your growing season your harvest and
your storage and dry
same thing with manufacturing production
facilities you have the intake and your
storage
while you're waiting to process your
your material then you have the actual
processing
and then the arguably one of your major
steps would be the bottling and
packaging
for labs you have your sample shipping
how does it get to the lab you know how
does
and what do you do with your intake how
do you do with your processing
uh and then storage and disposal you
won't talk too much about those
um because most labs have to be 17025
accredited
or will be soon and that pretty much
is covered a lot of that
for growers well we'll start
with your growing seasons so
if you are sourcing storing and
germinating your seed
how are you doing that how are you
storing your seed
a lot of seed comes with nice
fungal contamination to begin with
so why a lot of the commercial seed is
fungi
fungicide uh sprayed we do see
germination testing
in the lab and uh a good chunk of these
seeds that come through usually have
mold on them
for most people that isn't a big deal
but when you're doing
a large large large quantities of seed
you know are your workers protected for
that are they wearing respirators or
masks because if you're tossing around
all that dust that gets up in the air
then you've got fungal infections
in your grow houses in your potting
media
so if you're growing hydroponically
indoors
your uh lines your potting soil
how are you cleaning that yes it sounds
dumb to
say clean potting material and you want
microbes in that potting material
but are you checking in every once in a
while
are you looking to see if there's
anything in there that shouldn't be
what are you doing with your water lines
are you flushing them
occasionally your nutrient lines are are
they being cleaned out
what kind of frequency you know you're
going to get
some kind of fungal and algal bloom in
there eventually if you're not careful
but you can also get some really nasty
bacteria growing in those as well
you know and once you get outdoors
for mid to late season for most of those
guys
you know all again your irrigation tanks
and lines
uh what are you doing to keep those
clean
pests up in wisconsin for hemp we had
the
eurasian hemp water which brought a lot
of fungal disease with it
you know and you've got if you have too
much rain or if you have a drought
you can all these things can cause
fungal and bacterial
excuse me blooms and infections that
if you're not careful you can actually
cause harm to people that are working
and really any kind of stress to these
plants and plants in general
can cause these things
when you're harvesting your equipment
you know a lot of that harvesting
equipment if you're
granted you can't do a lot by a machine
yet
but if you're doing seed there's a lot
of dust that's popped up
and you know especially for the seed
then you also have fire
issues but that's a whole other thing
altogether once you
actually harvest it though how long
before it gets to
your storage location what is your
storage location like
what is it your storage facility made
out of you know
what are the conditions in that storage
location
your employees what are they doing how
are they
taking care of things are they washing
their hands are they
sick on site when they're cutting things
are they using
properly cleaned equipment for example
you know if you're gardening it's not
huge because you're harvesting a lot of
this stuff but
if you trim plants
without cleaning your equipment or
sanitizing your
shears you can easily spread fungal and
bacterial diseases
with plants which will hurt your crop
yield
and utterly lead to infection
and then you know whether what's your
climate like
that will change everything around and
while you can't change the climate
it definitely needs to be put into
or addressed so that you can actually
modify your other like your storage
location your drying location
so when you do begin to go drying and
store your samples
what's the environmental controls for
your location
is this just a shack that is
no electricity and you're just hanging
things drying things from there
you know is is it temperature controlled
humidity controlled
etc how long are you going to be keeping
the stuff there
is it going to be a week or two
until you get things dried down and then
you send them off to a facility are you
sending them to a facility right away
or you plan on winterizing this stuff it
all needs to be taken into account
and just as much how much
are you doing six acres ten acres or
is this a ten plant setup that you're
doing a test run on
that will change all of the other
quality control
and storage issues
and then also the conditioner crop are
you bring when you harvest is there a
patch that's moldy
that's infected this is diseased what
are you doing in that are you keeping
that separate and trying to actually get
something out of it
are you quarantining it when you bring
it in or are you just mixing in with the
general population and hoping when you
dry it out
it'll take care of itself are you just
throwing it out
so even burning it sometimes spores can
get kicked up
fungal spores can dislodge in the
heat in the air from the heat
and then spread around your drying
what is your airflow like you know all
of these things come to play
so what
exactly does that mean well what can you
have what kind of problems can you have
i'm going to focus a little more on some
of the more human pathogens
but there are a lot of just
general plants and fungal pathogens that
aren't even discussed on here that
we just don't have time to go through so
if you're not following things
if you're not putting these plans into
place
you know uh anthrax bacillus anthracis
it's actually a very common soil
pathogen
if you you know give a trained
microbiologist some aluminum foil on a
baked potato you can actually isolate
pure cultures of anthrax
in about an hour and a half now no that
doesn't mean that
you know you got to watch people on and
put people on watch lists
but you can actually as a way to culture
this
it's actually a very easy way
but it's also been an agricultural
infection problem for a very long time
tends to be limestone
but anywhere that you're growing stuff
what kind of
fertilizer are you using are you using
manure
do you have livestock on the property
this is in the soil so it can be part
of the area
as i mentioned before and brought up
actually in two slides
the irrigation lines and indoor outdoor
uh legionella
sorry legionella pneumophila also causes
uh legionnaires disease there was
actually somebody
in the industry that got caught this
from their potting soil in an indoor
grow house
last year i believe this is also very
very very common
in uh sprinkler lines that are not
flushed
regularly so is this coming in your
irrigation lines how often are you
cleaning them because it loves
stagnant water so if you are not
cycling that water really fast and if
it's sitting for quite a while this is a
very
very big possibility and these this guy
sneaks up on you
it does not culture well uh you have to
look
specifically for it and it
isn't the frontline antibiotics are not
great
for it they'll work occasionally but
you can go everywhere from this from
coughing to
full-on organ failure shutdown and it
takes about
three to four weeks or can anyways
so a fungal version of all of these good
things eucharomycosis
uh you've got several different versions
of it flavors
and fusarium is one of the species that
causes it
there's also a few other ones but these
are all pretty common soil environmental
fungi it's not nice
and uh while it does tend to be
more for immunocompromised patients it
doesn't help that if you're
even normally healthy
and everybody knows about aspergillus
but our fun black
you know quote black mold and uh
this is the one that most people
actually test for when they say
mycotoxins or fungal
cultures again here's fusarium it can
also cause its own
special cases of infection again
immune compromised people
on the manufacturing and processing side
what are some areas that you should be
looking at to help with
well when your product comes in with has
the farmer had it tested how did the
farmer actually take care of their stuff
you really need to watch where your
farmers you got to trust them are they
doing things properly or they're drying
properly
because that much organic material in a
wet area
is just as you most of you well know
that's a lovely lovely playground for
all kinds of mold
um you know when you're building a
storage warehouse or your facility
you're going to want to look at your
humidity and temperature for inside
if those fluctuate even you can cause
problems microclimates
in specific warehouses can be a major
problem
uh the type of construction materials
used for your floors for your shelves
for your buildings
is it wood is it stainless steel is it
aluminum
is it you know go down the list how easy
is it for you to clean
is really where i'm getting at with this
and then again air flow good air flow is
essential if you want to store anything
for a long term
and avoid bacterial and fungal
contamination
how are those samples stored what are
your containers like are they airtight
is this vacuum sealed is this stuck and
bales just stuck on shelves
you know what's the lighting in your
facility
not only does are they showing light
breaks down
uh cbd cda that kind of thing
but if you have
a dark area with bad
airflow and you have a microclimate of
decaying
plant material you have a chance of your
entire storage facility
going up with fungal infection or fungal
contamination
you got tossed out whole batches that's
not a good thing
and your personnel how are your
employees
handling the material are they clean are
they bringing in anything from outside
are do you have them wearing lab coats
or
just you know things specifically for
your facility
a lot of places will have sticky mats or
bleach mats
you know how your employees take care of
themselves
and reduce the cross-contamination risk
so that even if you do have
a region of your facility that gets a
contamination
problem you're not going to spread it to
the rest of your
facility and contain it
when you begin processing say you're
taking in bulk biomass that's dried
you load everything up into that
gigantic grinder
well there's a good chance even as much
as you try to there's going to be fungal
spores on some of that
so get your employees to start wearing
respirators if they're not already ppe
is
huge for this plus
be careful that when you're putting this
stuff into a room you want to make sure
that it's in a room that you can clean
easily and the equipment you're cleaning
on a
very very regular basis so something
that you
if it's stainless steel you know bleach
is always good
onionated quasal is always very nice
there's lots of fungal and bacterial
decontamination sprays you can get but
if you're at every step of your process
if you get that contaminated everything
downstream of that
gets contaminated so every batch
afterwards until you catch it is
contaminated
so that also then can be
problems for you and your employees
health wise but
as from a product standpoint you don't
want to screw up
batches and batches and batches a day
with cross-contamination so not only do
you have to pull down your equipment
take it apart clean it bring it back up
make sure it's specked
and that takes anywhere from only half a
day to three days depending on your
equipment but everywhere everything that
you've run through you have to then test
and perhaps most likely throw out
this is arguable so the manufacturing
bottling and packaging step is arguably
one of your
bigger quality control risk areas for
fungal bacterial
infection and contamination all of your
equipment and machinery needs to be
sanitized
i mean general fda guidelines
are you need to be doing batch testing
and lot testing for
all of your products just for human
safety wise
but this is where you get into major
recalls
from other products and other uh
industries
and you really need to be on your a-game
make sure everything is clean make sure
everything is taken care of what are
your bottles
are you using are they sterilized
beforehand are you using mylar packaging
you know are they clear bottles are the
amber bottles are they
you know your packaging really really
really
keep an eye on your processes here some
of the things that can come up
especially in your bottling packaging
we all know about e coli but in
particular
everyone hears about o157h7 which is
what tends to be your food poisoning
there are also a large number of other
ones
that cause disease and there's also a
large number that does not
but you this is you're going to get this
from
improperly hand washing
cross-contamination with fertilizers
and other areas
staph aureus this is pretty common
everywhere
i believe uh up to 25
of people are already colonized of it
with it
and it's in your nose your armpits your
uh
tends to be your crotch and uh i cannot
remember off top of my head where the
other one is
um but you know we've all heard about
staph infections mrsa infections
this can also cause food poisoning so
again with bottling packaging
keep an eye on it
clostridium c diff you've probably heard
about
very very nasty antibiotic resistant
anaerobic so it doesn't like oxygen this
is
one of the worries is that it is in your
oil bottles because oil does not really
like to transfer
oxygen so at the bottom of your oil
bottles
anybody who's canned food knows about uh
clostridium botulinum
and or botox is the isolated toxin from
c botulinum
and uh perfringens calcium perfringens
is another one these are all
anaerobes and you know again they're
pretty common
everywhere so it's something to keep an
eye on
and more for the extraction facilities
themselves
um pseudomonas aeruginosa now
this guy it's a gram-negative aerobic it
rod that tends to be in the environment
a lot if
you're on a if you go to a water
fountain and you see that blue
uh crud on the water fountain
that usually is pseudomonas it
releases a dye um
or a pigment that can turn that blue
but these guys are extremely hearty i
personally have seen them growing and
thriving
and five percent ammonia quantile on a
lab bench
it so they can adapt they also like to
live in corners and crusts
and creases so when you're cleaning out
your
equipment this is one of the things that
you would be screening for
in your own internal qa qc
so after all that what can you do about
all this stuff
yeah you know i gave you the scary
bacteria and fungi
um really
you're looking at having standard
operating procedures
you're looking at having qualified
vendors and
making sure your supplies are the same
you know the you want to have all the
documentation with those supplies
you want to make sure that your
employees are wearing the correct
equipment or ppe so are they wearing
gloves for things to reduce
contamination issues that you have
uh you know are you using the proper
supplies for the situation
are you cleaning your utensils in the
correct bit
do you have an autoclave you know are
you using the correct cleaner for the
correct
surface are your you know certain
percentages of bleach will not
kill off bacterial and fungal spores but
it'll kill off live bacteria
hand sanitizer does not kill bacterial
spores
does not kill fungal spores and to be
honest
a lot of viruses it doesn't actually
take care of either
so you would you know need to wash your
hands
but really there are so many avenues
to watch for that you need to take care
of
and really use the right tools
and as i said before if you don't write
it down if you don't log it
it didn't happen so keeping track of
these things so that when
oh you might say you see a little bit of
a problem with
oh you might have had a little bacterial
infection
about six months ago now it's starting
to pop up a lot more
you can then kind of trace back
and say oh well maybe it's from the
supplier or maybe
we have a reservoir somewhere in our
facility that this is coming from or
maybe it's a specific individual
who doesn't seem to want to wash their
hands
um it really really helps
you keep track and address things down
the road
and having a plan to address things so
what will you do
if you have a contamination problem
do you have a plan for that as long as
you have a plan
at least it's a start uh it'll mitigate
most of the things
you know how are you going to address
keeping things from coming into your
facility
how are you going to keep your drawing
set up
so that anybody who comes in any
employee that comes in
knows how to do things right away and
then training them on it
so really there's a lot more you can go
into
and there's a lot of areas that can be
delved into but the biggest thing is
just having a plan
writing it down and using the correct
tool for the occasion it sounds really
simple when you say it that way but
in reality that's the way a lot of it
comes down to
so i guess that's
uh pretty much all i have if anybody has
any questions
feel free to let me know and uh
i'll try to answer them as best as i can
thanks